I really want to start with a sincere
congrats I really enjoyed this movie I
thought Francis did a great job with it
um is it is it a little weird for all
three of you is it a little weird
signing on to something when you know
there's going to be so much VFX and
you're not exactly sure how it's all
going to turn out or do you sort of have
like oh Francis Lawrence knows what he's
doing this is going to be great
the latter
deformer
and I loved the story and I was just
like you know what this is going to be
great I just want to be in it anyways
and experience and I was you know I
expected a lot but I was so so happy and
more than my imagination could imagine
it's how it looks yeah I couldn't have
imagined it to look as incredible as it
does it really is I mean visually yeah
it's absolutely I can't believe it I
watched it with my wife a few weeks ago
in screening room and we just kept going
I've taken it on and uh what you call it
in a an honest way I wasn't so much
worried about the CG stuff because I'm
the only one that's really in the
non-dream world I was like I'm gonna as
long as I'm there in the table at the
table we're all good and I feel like the
table was the table Yeah they nailed
that
yeah you know the uh it's it it's it's
that's right because the visual effects
are earned by the storyline and that's
that's the that's what you're that's
what you're looking for and hoping for
when you choose a film like this yeah
and it happened exceeded expectations
yes and was talking to Francis about
this I don't know if you realize but
like the VFX industry is kind of effed
right now there's a lot of things that
are behind the scenes and so it's a
miracle that the visual effects in this
look as good as they do I didn't know
that that's interesting that is I'd like
to hear that that historians oh I can
just tell you a lot of directors I know
that are waiting on VFX shots and
Francis even said they had a lot of
issues on this movie getting the VFX
done but that I won't waste your time
with all of it but you can ask for
instance about it so it's an
extraordinary job that they've done yeah
no I I agree for all three of you is it
nice to be in something and maybe this
is the reason you signed on but is it
nice to be in something that the entire
family can watch like every one of your
relatives you can sit around and you
know share this with them yes
definitely as well did I cut you off no
that's true I use one word
I've got a six-year-old niece and the
whole time I was doing this I could not
wait to see her watch this and see me in
this and something she can enjoy and you
know tell her friends that's my auntie
Auntie so that was a real driving force
for me and she is you know the person
I'm most excited to see and see what her
reaction is to see if she respects me or
not so I'll let you know if she respects
me or not after this yeah and I
understand I've got a seven and a five
year old so it's going to be it's that
it's definitely going to get a lot of
play in our house and it's a proper
Adventure there's a treasure map how
many movies have a treasure map in them
anymore it's got that real kind of
Goonies Labyrinth feel and I'm kind of
excited to pass on that kind of
Storytelling to my kids yeah something I
also really appreciated about the script
is that it doesn't talk down to kids
treats kids with a lot of respect
um can you sort of talk about that
aspect that this is not watering it down
it's a smart script it in on the outside
of it all it deals with a a serious
issue of of grief and loss and uh what
have you but uh it's wrapped up in this
story and uh I think for for young
children they're able to uh
um if they've gone through some uh grief
or whatever they're they're able to see
some expression of it in a film like
this which is why we all go to films we
all have grief and we all have a uh
thoughts of this and ways we've dealt
with it and so everyone can relate to to
what this film's it's it's a it's a
human story like that it just happens to
be wrapped up in a in a great adventure
with treasure maps and Jason Momoa
running around with horns and sharp
teeth and all the rest of it and it's
just all around a great story and she's
not well done you know she's grieving
how she's what what she's doing she's
active in this kind of Adventure she is
she's not only the the protagonist she
is also the the action herself
everything that happens this all thing
happens here at the beginning but then
henceforth she is driving the plot
forward which is so exciting and that's
kind of I think what you mean when you
say this is from the from the from the
point of view from the child you want
them to be the protagonist for all three
of you for soon to be fans of this movie
is there anything that you think they
would be surprised to learn about the
actual making of the film I don't know I
had to go through two quarantines
this was shot during
yeah it was crazy we didn't well we
weren't we weren't allowed to meet each
other yeah that was strange so we I
didn't meet Jason until the last day of
the shoot
and I didn't meet you guys until after
yeah yeah really no it's wild um before
I met Jason yeah how was the pig nice
yeah that's what I heard
I did not hear that about the pig I
actually heard a big diva when I met him
he was pretty small well I met him at
the beginning of shooting so he the
stuff about him not coming out of the
trailer that's a lie after lunch
that was fine
how didn't he
um 403 of you another one uh if someone
is this is gonna be a curveball if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why I'm gonna go with moon boy just
because I wrote it so it's probably more
about me than anything else
I'm gonna go with this
[Music]
you want afterwards I don't want anyone
to see any of my work I like people to
like me
I'd start with bloodline
I'm curious what does Francis actually
like on set because I'm always curious
how a director likes to direct actors is
he giving you when he wants something
like a few words is he pulling you aside
and having a full-on conversation you
know what was he actually like to work
with speaking for myself it was a
friendly collaborative relationship
where
you you were playing together and it was
a safe atmosphere too it's nice for
actors to feel safe with a competent
director and a very good director but uh
so it was a it was a great atmosphere
yeah and I think it he he spoke when he
felt he needed things to be put across
rather than just to fill the silence
yeah I thought he let me do what I
wanted to do and I always appreciate a
director who does that who gives me the
freedom to explore the character for
myself and um then he'd just come and
you know say a few words say do you want
to try it this way shall we try it this
way so it wasn't more of a demand but
more of a discussion and if I was happy
to do that and most of the time I was
because I completely trusted him but I
did enjoy that he let me do my own thing
with it and then added a little bit of
paprika and salt and some seasoning on
it I love it of course that was funny he
wasn't having temper tantrum yeah
yelling the flamethrowers surprising man
yeah the casserole
I need to stop I'm just going to say
congrats on being part of it I know this
is going to be a big hit for people
um congrats and have a fantastic day
thank you very much